Michaela finally you know she went off
to University and it didn't go well she
couldn't even get to her classes she was
in such rough shape one day I took her
to a naturopath and they wanted to put
it on an Elimination Diet so she decided
she would do an Elimination Diet like I
wanted but she would decide what it was
going to be and I think she ate chicken
and broccoli for about a month and some
of her problems started to go away when
she ate things other than meat she
didn't feel good Michaela told me that
she had gone back to meat and her
Depression had lifted her arthritis had
lifted like everything was lifting wow
like completely